this is a production of Cornell
University so today I'm going to be
talking about a project that I've been
working on for about the past year and a
half I'm just in the middle of it still
so don't have any end conclusions but so
first I'll start off by talking about
the project that I'm working under so
the pheno apps project is a group of
computer programmers and plant
scientists we're working together
directly with breeders to develop apps
smartphone apps for the phenotyping of
plants these apps will then be deployed
through breeder networks especially in
developing countries and one of the
crops that the phenotypes project is
especially interested in is cassava so
we talked a lot about cassava in this
department but I thought I'd go over it
again cassava is both an industrial and
a food crop and it's a staple for over
800 million people especially in the
tropics primary breeding targets of
cassava are pest and disease resistance
yield and field performance and dry
matter content today I'm going to be
focusing mostly on dry matter cotton so
because I have a root dry matter content
is the proportion or the percent of the
root that is not water so after the
water leaves the root it's so it's
typically around 20 to 45 percent and up
to 90 percent of that can be starch it
directly affects the dry yield of the
cassava roots and also the food quality
or the mouthfeel which then it which
then affects the consumer acceptance and
the variety adoption rate of cassava and
in talking to breeders I found over and
over that this trait is notoriously
difficult time consuming laborious to
measure the two methods that are
typically used are specific gravity and
the oven method the specific gravity
method here on Left involves weighing
the roots in air and water
and then plugging those values into an
equation to get the dry matter content
the oven method requires transport from
the field to a laboratory setting where
the samples are dried in an oven after
shredding and this requires consistent
electricity which might not always be
present in every given location and so
because of the challenges the time put
in and the labor put in different
breeding programs have been looking at a
new technique to phenotype dry matter
content a little quicker and so this is
near-infrared spectroscopy or nears so
it's been shown to be highly predictive
of dry matter in cassava roots and this
because of this it's being routinely
used at sea at in Colombia for the
typing of dry matter cassava
but the validated spectrometers that
have been looked at so far are
prohibitively expensive for most small
breeding programs to afford so because
of this we're looking into the use of a
portable handheld spectrometer called
the SIA which at $300 is a 150 to 200
times price reduction from these other
spectrometers cost so it does measure a
restricted amount of wavelengths in the
near-infrared spectrum area of the
electromagnetic spectrum but as I'll
talk about we've found this to also be
highly predictive of dry matter content
and then the spectrometer connects with
bluetooth to a smartphone app that can
then be used by breeders and technicians
in the field to collect data so now I'm
gonna take a little step back and talk
about what the infrared spectroscopy is
so this is a method that allows for a
quick and non-destructive analyses it's
been used in lots of different fields
including you can tell medications apart
like counterfeit or not counterfeit and
then in agriculture specifically it's
been used for cultivar identification
for measuring bricks and other traits
and what it is is the spectrometer
measures the reflectance of light in
near
for red region of the electromagnetic
spectrum which goes from about 700 and
the reflectance in this region
represents a complex signal from the
physical and chemical properties of
whatever is being scanned
so because the signal is complex
it requires multivariate statistical
techniques to be able to decipher what's
going on and then it also requires the
development of calibration models for
use in each and every application so
this cultivar identification in beans
will require a different model from
measuring bricks and apples and so in my
case this looks like three main steps
first the calibration data is collected
and then that data is fed as training
data into a prediction model development
pipeline and once those models are
developed they can be used for routine
analysis in breeding programs so this
requires protocol optimization to decide
what different steps need to be put into
the data collection protocol and also
into the model development pipeline and
then once the models are developed they
will also require consistent updating as
the phenotype change as environments
change so I'm gonna zoom in and talk
about my work in steps one two and the
protocol optimization so I have two
different breeding programs that I'm
working with ITA in Nigeria and not gree
in Uganda each with two different years
of data so far I just have this first
year collected my now sees for the rest
of the presentation will focus on these
trials in Nigeria which include 129
genotypes total with two reps each these
data were collected with six routes per
plot the roots were sliced in half
crossways and then scanned
cross-sectionally these are more slices
than were actually taken it was just cut
in half scan like this and then the
those same routes were put in through
the standard operating protocol for the
oven method to determine
content and this was done for each
individual route so for each route I
have a pairing of scans and a dry matter
content value from the oven method these
were then fed into pre-processing
techniques and then into my model
development pipeline which consisted of
50 iterations of random split of 70%
training and 30% validation to get a
better idea of what different training
sets well what the effect of different
training sets will have on the
predictive ability of the models and so
then I looked specifically at the
different pre-processing techniques and
their effect on the models themselves so
I looked at 12 different techniques
including scattered correction and
derivatives and compared them with the
raw data values so this graph shows from
left to right on the x-axis different
pre-processing techniques with raw data
on the far left the top is predictive
ability of the model with our squared
prediction in the bottom is root mean
squared error of prediction and as you
can see there's no statistically
significant difference between the
different pre-processing methods and the
raw data itself so I will use this to
inform my model development pipeline
moving forward but I'll keep checking it
with different data sets as the data
itself might require different
pre-processing methods so one other
thing that I looked at in the protocol
optimization is the number of routes
that I included for plot so if you
remember I had the dry matter content
for each individual route and I used
that in this analysis so from left to
right we have 1 through 6 routes per
plot and then this is the r-squared
prediction again and the root mean
squared error of prediction and there
are clear advantages to adding more
routes but there seem to be diminishing
returns after about three routes and
then this again will be used to inform
the future calibration data collection
and the SOPs that we develop for
breeding programs to
and their routine phenotyping of dry
matter contents and so with this our our
final goal is that routine use of this
method in breeding programs but to get
there we have Additional Protocol
optimization that I'd like to perform
and then additional data from the other
breeding program in Uganda as well as
from 2019 and then I'd like to evaluate
prediction models across environments
and breeding programs and then finally
integrate this data type and the models
that I create into cassava base so that
breeders can access I'd like to thank my
lab and my great collaborators from the
next-gen cassava project if you know
Epstein are there any questions for
Jenna Joan is how repeatable are these
did you try measuring the same roots two
or three or four times so I scanned each
root six times and so far have been
averaging the scans across the root but
I do want to look at the number of scans
per sample to see if that's affecting
the results that I'm getting so looking
at once can per root and comparing it
with another scan for the root or
averaging two or three to see how many
we should be so it's not something I've
looked at yet but I do
so the question is whether we're exactly
on the route the scans are taking place
and how that affects and the results
that so I've been we're taking the route
and cutting it in half crossways in the
middle and then taking three scans on
each half both on the cut surface so we
have not so far looked at different
regions of the route so we do know that
dry matter can vary from the proximal to
distal end of the route and that is
something else that we want to look at
so we do have a collaborator at Umbra in
Brazil who's looking at this right now
and I've been talking to him about
getting that data and looking at it but
so far the roots have all been the same
age roughly the same size and so that
also is not what is the relationship
between dry matter and consumer
acceptance so all that I know about that
is secondhand from readers and from
people who saw a few of them but they
all say that the higher dry matter is
better it just feels better in your
mouth it cooks better and so I think
that consumers can can tell whether a
route is higher low dry matter when
they're eating it and then it might mean
that they don't buy cassava from that
person who sold the low dry matter
cassava to them or something like that
but I haven't done any direct consumer
studies or anything like that any other
questions
all right on let's give Jenna another
round of applause
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu